so you've said that individual humans
are multi-layered susceptible to signals
and waves and multiple strata the
physical the biological social cultural
intellectual so
sort of going along these lines can you
describe
the layers of the cake that that is a
human being
and maybe the human collective human
society
so i'm just stealing wholesale here from
robert persig
who is the author of zen in the art of
motorcycle maintenance and in his um
follow-on
book
uh has a sequel to it called lila he
goes into this in a little more detail
but um it's it's a it's a crude approach
to thinking about people but i think
it's still an advancement over
traditional subject object metaphysics
where we look at people as a dualist
would say well is this your mind er you
know your consciousness is that
is that just merely the matter that's in
your brain or is there something kind of
more beyond that and they would say yes
there's a soul sort of ineffable
soul beyond just merely the physical
body right and then and i'm not one of
those people right i think that we don't
have to draw a line between
are things only this or only that
collectives of things can emerge
structures and patterns that are just as
real as the underlying pieces but you
know they're transcendent but they're
still of the underlying pieces
so your body is this way i mean we just
know physically you consist of atoms and
uh and and whatnot and then the atoms
are arranged into molecules which then
arrange into certain kinds of structures
that seem to have a homeostasis to them
we call them cells and those cells form
you know sort of biological structures
those biological structures give your
body
its physical ability and biological
ability to consume energy and to
maintain homeostasis but humans are
social animals i mean human by
themselves is is not very long for the
world so we also part of our biology is
wire to connect to other people to you
know from the mirror neurons to our
language uh centers and all these other
things
so
we are intrinsically there's a layer
there's a part of us that wants to be
part of a thing if we're around other
people not saying a word but they're
just up and down jumping and dancing
laughing we're gonna feel better right
and they didn't there was no exchange of
physical anything they didn't give us
like five atoms of happiness right but
there's an induction in our own sense of
self that is at that social level
and then beyond that um
person puts the intellectual level kind
of one level higher than social i think
they're actually more intertwined than
than that but the intellectual level is
the the level of pure ideas that you are
a vessel for memes you're a vessel for
philosophies
you will conduct yourself in a
particular way
i mean i think part of this is if we
think about it from a physics
perspective you're not you know there's
a joke that physicists like to
approximate things and we'll say well
approximate a spherical cowl right
you're not a spherical cow you're not a
spherical human you're a messy human and
we can't even um say what the dynamics
of your emotion will be unless we
analyze all four of these layers
right if it's if you're if you're muslim
at a certain time of day guess what
you're going to be on the ground
kneeling and praying right and that has
nothing to do with your biological need
to get on the ground or physics of
gravity it is an intellectual drive that
you have it's a cultural phenomenon and
an intellectual belief that you carry so
that's what the four-layered stack
um
is is all about it's that a person's not
only one of these things they're all of
these things at the same time it's a
superposition
of dynamics that run through us that
make us who we are
so no layers is special
um not so much nowhere especially each
layer is just different
um but we are
each layer against the participation
trophy
yeah each layer is a part of what you
are you are a layer cake right of all
these things and if we try to deny
right so many philosophies do try to
deny
the reality of some of these things
right some people say well we're only
atoms well we're not only atoms because
there's a lot of other things that are
only atoms i can reduce a human being to
a bunch of soup and it's not they're not
the same thing even though it's the same
atoms so i think the the order and the
patterns that emerge within humans
um to understand
to really think about what a next
generation philosophy would look like
that would allow us to reason about
extending humans into the digital realm
or to interact with autonomous
intelligences that are not biological
nature we really need to appreciate
these that human what human beings
actually are is the superposition of
these different layers
you mentioned consciousness
are each of these layers of cake
conscious
is consciousness a particular quality of
one of the layers is there like a spike
if you have a consciousness detector at
these layers or it's something that just
permeates all of these layers and just
takes different form i believe what
humans experience as consciousness
is something that sits on a gradient
scale
of
a general principle in the universe that
seems to
look for order and reach for order when
there's an excess of energy you know
it's it would be odd to say a proton is
alive right it'd be odd to say like this
particular
atom or molecule of of hydrogen gas is
alive
but there's certainly something
we can make
assemblages of these things that cre
that are that have autopoetic aspects to
them that will create structures that
will you know crystalline solids will
form very interesting and beautiful
structures um this gets kind of into
weird mathematical territories you start
thinking about penrose and game of life
stuff uh about the generativity of math
itself like the hyper real numbers
things like that but um without going
down that rabbit hole i would say that
there seems to be a tendency
in the world that when there is
excess energy things will structure and
pattern themselves and they will then
actually furthermore try to create an
environment that furthers their
continued stability uh it's the concept
of externalized extended phenotype or
niche construction
so
um this is ultimately what leads to
certain kinds of amino acids forming
certain kinds of structures and so forth
until you get the ladder of life so what
we experience as consciousness no i
don't think cells are conscious of that
level but is there something beyond mere
equilibrium state biology and and
chemistry and biochemistry that drives
what makes things work
i think there is um
so adrian bajan has this constructable
law there's other things you look at
when you look at the life sciences and
you look at
any kind of statistical physics and
statistical mechanics
when you look at things far out of
equilibrium
when you have excess energy what happens
then life
doesn't just make a hotter soup it
starts making structure
there's something there
you